hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
two of the authors that lev chesterf is
going to bring up quite
often both on their own and in relation
to each other in all things are possible
are friedrich nietzsche and theodore
dostoevsky the one of them
a german-born and german language
philosopher but somebody who also worked
with literature as we'll talk about soon
and the other a novelist and short story
writer from
russia who has a lot of philosophical
ideas in the mouths of his characters
and in the discussions that they have
with each other in the lives that they
live and as it turns out uh if you
look through chestnut's corpus you will
actually find a book
specifically on theodore dostoevsky and
friedrich nietzsche
and he calls this the the philosophy of
tragedy dostoevsky and nietzsche right
so this is quite important chesterf
is what we can call one of the very
first of the second
wave of existentialists one of the
people who
realizes the continuity of ideas and
approaches
between the people who we identify as
the first wave
in particular in his case dostoevsky
nietzsche really early on
later on he realizes that kierkegaard is
doing something
similar it brought to his attention in
the late
twenties and you could say that
shestoff is one of several people who is
drawing
these connections another who he
mentions in the book a little bit later
on
is georg brandes the danish writer
who lectures on nietzsche and he sort of
criticizes nietzsche for getting a
little bit
too much enamored with fame late in his
life
because brandace is now talking about
him
so what we can do in thinking about the
importance
of nietzsche and dostoevsky
is look at the passages where they're
being brought up together
and then look at the things that chef
stuff has to say about them
individually and as it turns out there
are quite a few
places where they are being discussed
together so one of these is in chapter
50
where he calls them inverted
simulators he says nietzsche and
dostoevsky seem to be typical inverted
simulators if one may use the expression
simulation is deceiving is is putting
forth something
what did they do they imitated spiritual
sanity
although they were spiritually insane
they knew their morbidity well enough
but they exhibited their disease
only to that extent where freakishness
passes
for originality with the sensitiveness
peculiar to all who are in constant
danger
they never went beyond the limits the
acts of the guillotine of public opinion
hung over them one awkward move
and the execution automatically takes
place but they knew
how to avoid unwarrantable moves so what
he's saying there
is that they weren't people who were
particularly
well or integrated but they did have
some
very useful insights and they did it in
such a way
as to continually push and push and push
but not incur some sort of public
opinion
wrath that would have would have
destroyed the efforts that they were
putting forward so that's kind of an
interesting
idea another he talks about
how they viewed conscience
and he says here
here we go while conscience stands
between the educated and lower classes
the only possible mediator there can be
no hope for mutual understanding
conscience demands sacrifices nothing
but sacrifices it says to the educated
man
you are happy well off learned that
people are poor unhappy ignorant
renounce your well-being or soothe your
conscience with suave
speeches and this is in fact what
tolstoy himself will do later on right
and here's where he says something
really interesting about these two
thinkers
this is why dostoevsky and nietzsche
were not afraid to speak in their own
name
why because he says only the person who
has nothing to sacrifice nothing to lose
having
lost everything can hope to approach the
people
as an equal how did dostoevsky lose
everything
well i mean he was lined up
in a what he thought was an execution
and they then after not executing him
shipped him off to prison in siberia
with all these other people who had been
sent out there
uh in a very rough environment for
for years he comes back and begins
writing
and he's never until the end of his life
in any sort of secure
financial position not least because he
gambles away
his earnings in many cases right he's
frantically writing
in order to pay off debts he understands
what it's like to not really have
anything
you could say something similar about
nietzsche nietzsche you know he does
attain a nice
position as a professor but then has to
leave it due to illness and he's
continually struggling with the
illnesses of his life
and also trying to get across ideas
that for the most part are not
particularly welcome as a matter of fact
nietzsche enjoys a much greater
reputation
after he's committed to a sanatorium and
not doing any any work
than he does during his lifetime of
alternating bed rest and
frantic periods of writing and thinking
so
this is why dostoevsky and nietzsche
were not afraid to speak in their own
name
and here's the interesting addition to
that they did not feel compelled to
stretch
up or to stoop down in order to be on a
level
with other human beings they could just
be where they were
and you know speak to to anybody at any
level so that's another interesting
feature shestop also remarks
that in some cases their works are
you know really great in in other cases
um
like he says sense and folly are not at
all native qualities
in a person in a crisis a stupid person
becomes clever
and you know he says who do we look at
for an example
what a gaping simpleton dostoyevsky
looks
in his injured and insulted not to
mention
poor folk these early works right but
in letters from the underground and the
rest of his books he is the shrewdest
and cleverest of
writers so something happens that
transforms
their perspective and they gain insights
that they can communicate
he also says the same may be said of
nietzsche tolstoy or shakespeare
in his birth of tragedy nietzsche seems
just like the ordinary honest rather
simple blue-eyed provincial german
student
and in zarathustra he reminds one of
machiavelli so
you know nietzsche actually criticizes
the birth of tragedy himself later on i
think it's a great work
but shestop did not share that opinion
and he shared nietzsche's own
self-condemnation but in the rest of his
work
it's quite brilliant isn't it the other
thing that
he suggests that's uh similar about
these two
is that they both take to literature and
they take to literature
for a particular reason and you might
say wait a second
dostoevsky wrote literature nietzsche
okay he wrote the spoke zarathustra and
that's literature i guess
you did write some poetry as well um
and he wrote some music which is not
particularly good music
but most of his work is is philosophy
isn't it or
philology at least what we would now
call linguistics and classics
and yes that's kind of correct but
if you look at his style is it really
straight
out philosophy i mean it's much more
like chef stuff
and his form of writing i mean the most
systematic work in
in after birth of tragedy would be the
genealogy of morals
which has three essays but look at it
read the book
it's actually ranging all over you know
different things and it's organized into
different paragraphs
they don't all map on to each other
systematically then
look at you know uh other works where
it's aphorisms after aphorisms after
aphorism so that is literature
and what's going on with that
um well here's the the context
so shasta says
um in the order of decor in the interest
of order and decorum
people will grant you a not too
important place in their philosophy of
life
for any philosophy of life as in a
cemetery a place is prepared
for each and all and everyone is welcome
there are also enclosures where rubbish
is dumped to rot but for those who have
as yet no desire to be fit into a world
philosophy
i would advise them to keep their tongue
between their teeth or
like nietzsche and dostoevsky take
to literature take to literature
why because in literature you can do
what you can't do
in a philosophy of life for example you
can have characters like
like dostoyevsky does who talk about
philosophy
and sometimes get it right and sometimes
get it wrong but are teaching us
something
in the process making us think further
so you know nietzsche is doing something
similar in his
reception of philosophy as well let's
talk about nietzsche then
uh on his own so one of the things that
shestoff picks up from nietzsche that is
really
central to his work is that um you know
philosophy
and other things like philosophy like
science
like other systematic approaches to
things these do not come
out of some sort of absolute necessity
that we managed to discover
about the world about life about the
human mind
these ah priorities as we can call them
instead like he says the root of all of
our philosophies lies
not in our objective observations but in
the demands of our own heart in the
subjective moral
will so that you know the ways in which
people do
philosophy arise out of their
as nietzsche says biography they arise
out of the
logic of their life and their desires
and their experiences
so there's another realization here as
well
he talks about nietzsche's instinct
not being at fault that science cannot
be uprooted unless we first destroy
morality and again if we think about
the genealogy of morals and in
particular the third essay
you know science did not simply
replace religion and previous
metaphysics
with its own correct positivist point of
view
and sweep away all that detritus it
actually science is a new form of
theology
science is a new form of metaphysics
that thinks that it's advanced
further but is really driven by the same
will of truth the same asceticism as
those others that were a little bit more
disorganized
and had in some respects you know
blocked views but also further views
than
the blinkered eye of the scientist
he also talks about at one point i think
this is quite
worth thinking about something that
could be the key to the philosophy
of nietzsche here's what he says
this comes up in a discussion about
essentially skepticism he says we have
sufficient grounds for taking life
mistrustfully
it has defrauded us so often of our
cherished expectations
so we could you know we can distrust
life but then he says
we have still stronger grounds for
mistrusting reason
if reas if life deceived us it was only
because
futile reason let herself be
deceived maybe reason herself invented
the deception
and then to serve her own ambitious ends
threw the blame on life
so that life shall appear sick headed
so the problem isn't really life it's
it's actually
rationality as applied to life and he
says if we have to choose between life
and reason we choose life
then we no longer need to try to foresee
and explain we can wait and accept
all that is unalterable as part of the
game
so this is an interesting idea we are
disappointed by life we are disappointed
by reason where should we
lay the blame what should we do in that
case
here's where he brings up nietzsche and
he says thus nietzsche having realized
all his hopes had gradually crumbled he
could never get back to his former
strength but must grow worse
every day wrote in a private letter
i and this is in german
as hot i i have it's you know more
difficult
now than anybody else and he goes
on and says that that he has
the good conscience to possess
something that few people have and have
had
right flugul um in gleichnissa zuraiden
right and he says this is the key to the
philosophy of of nietzsche and so that's
kind of an interesting idea that
nietzsche's
own philosophy is developing under the
impetus
of realizing that even he has been
screwed over by life
and reason and he's not going to get the
time back he's not going to get the days
of health back
he has to figure out what to do and
whether he's going to accept it
let's talk about dostoevsky so
here shesta has a really
incisive uh insight
this is in chapter 54 of part one it's
better to be an unhappy man
than a happy pig the utilitarians hope
by this golden bridge to get over the
chasm which separates them from the
promised land
of the ideal so the utilitarians there
is jon stewart mill
better to be socrates dissatisfied than
a pig satisfied
and why did he say that because people
were accusing the utilitarians of just
being pigs
basically you're like the epicureans and
you know if you know anything about the
epicureans you know they didn't live
like pigs right
so the epicureans are actually quite
prudish
and and you might even say kind of
boring heatedness
and many utilitarians are as well and
then he said but psychology stepped in
and rudely interrupted
there are no there are no unhappy people
the unhappy ones are all
pigs if people are unhappy it's because
they're
desiring things that they shouldn't
desire right and then he says
dostoevsky's philosopher of the
underworld
rashka rashikalanakov also hamlet and
such like
are not simply unhappy men whose fate
might be esteemed or even preferred
they're simply unhappy swine right
and so is this right is is
is shasta saying that dostoyevsky is
throwing in our face these
unhappy people who really are just pigs
um i think he's using this to actually
challenge
utilitarianism and but also at the same
time to say
you know a lot of these characters are
kind of dirt bags
even ivan karamazov you know he's got
some good points to him
but there's also some bad sides of
actually all the car above us right
dealing with struggle dostoevsky is kind
of a battleground
between europe and russia which was an
issue
that was plaguing russian thought what
should we accept from those europeans
and he goes on and he's got a few
interesting things to say
about how dostoyevsky
you know compared to tolstoy was even
more
driven by his passions dolstoyeski's
dislike of tergenia was stronger than
tolstoy's he wrote of him very
spitefully and offensively
libeling him rather than drawing a
caricature even a caricature would be
offensive he libels him evidently
dostoevsky like tolstoy detested the
european
in their confrare and then he says to
dostoyevsky it was enough that tergenia
wore european clothes and tried to
appear like a westerner dostoevsky did
the opposite
he tried to get rid of every trace of
europeanism from himself
apparently without great success since
he failed to make clear to himself
wherein lay the strength of europe and
wear his
sting so dostoyevsky is a conflicted
person who is trying to work out you
know this this sort of
age-old question what should we accept
from those who seem to be more
culturally advanced
than ourselves and he you know if you
look at his characters
they engage in this discussion or
represent
different perspectives on it as well
he's also got a really interesting
discussion of what he calls
dostoyevsky's muddled relations
with morality and this is in in
discussion of
of women and attitudes towards
women so we could contrast
this against you know gogol
and pushkin and some of these others and
tolstoy
as well and then we get to dostoyevsky
and he says dostoevsky had very muddled
relations with morality
he was too racked by disease and
circumstance
to get much profit out of the rules of
morality the hygiene of the soul like
that of the body
is beneficial only to healthy people to
the sick
it is simply harmful you might actually
do better
to ease up on the rules if you're
a sick person psychologically or
physically
he says the more that dostoevsky engaged
himself with high morality
the more inextricably entangled he
became and so stuff uses the example of
relations with with women
at this point he says he wanted to
respect the personality in a woman
and only the personality so he came to
the point where he could not look on any
woman
however ugly with indifference the elder
karamazov has an affair
with stinking lizzie in what other
imagination could such a union have been
contemplated
dostoevsky of course reprimands
karamazov
and thanks to the standards of modern
criticism such a reprimand is accounted
a sufficient exonerator author but there
are other standards
so he you know he's saying that
dostoevsky even when it comes to
morality the characters explore morality
but don't dostoevsky himself is kind of
a conflicted person and that's part of
why we have so much we can learn
from him right um finally the the last
thing that he says that i think is
particularly interesting about
dostoyevsky
and this applies to him as an author
through his characters
here chest off is talking about
something that we ought to do
and then he uses dostoevsky as an
example he says the best way of getting
getting rid of tedious played out truths
is to stop paying them the tribute of
respect and treat them with a touch of
easy familiarity
and derision joke about them lower them
these these truths that everyone is
supposed to believe in
so he says dostoevsky did this by
putting them into brackets
words like good self-sacrifice progress
and so on while you still contest a
certain truth he goes on you still
believe in it
putting it into brackets allows you
putting these words into brackets allows
you to
not take them as seriously and what does
he mean by brackets there well
these are actually quotation marks what
we call in english
in american english quotes right and
there's another meaning of bracketing
though that i think is also
kind of kind of useful here that we can
read in if we want to
when we talk about bracketing a claim
or a belief or something we're
suspending it we're not saying whether
it's correct or not we're
suspending our judgment about it and
we're kind of doing something like that
when we put something in
air quotes right we say such a
good person that's not the same thing as
saying such a good person
is it when we do the air quotes with it
so that's something that that you do see
dostoyevsky's characters doing in
different ways right
they they sometimes will do that
precisely
in the orthographic sense but they'll
also
frame things in their dialogue in such a
way they'll say i wanted to be a good
person
but then what is goodness really am i
being a good person in this this respect
i suppose you could say that i
am even though i've also got this other
motive going on
that is another form of bracketing
that's another form of calling
into question and so that's that's an
important part of
i would say dostoevsky's work in
arranging what his characters are going
to think
say do right so these
are some of the key points of what
chester thinks of and makes of
dostoyevsky
and nietzsche in all things are possible
he's in many respects following
in their footsteps and at certain points
going beyond
what what he thinks that they themselves
have done
as an existentialist author
you